The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, interactive
teaching.
Here is a famous graph produced
by Benjamin bloom and
his students.
So here on this axis is
student achievement.
So after a course is
over, students are
tested on the material.
And here's their score.
And this is the percentage
who attained each score.
So here, they compared three
methods of teaching, but I'll
just compare two.
So one method is standard
one-group instruction, say
one-to-30, or today,
maybe one-to-90.
And here is the histogram, the
distribution of students'
scores, nicely spread out.
Now, by itself, it
doesn't say much.
But what's really interesting is
the distribution base after
the same amount of teaching, but
done in a tutorial form,
with one-to-one or
maybe one-to-two.
You can put some quantitative
figures on this
from Bloom's results.
The average--
so this is one-to-one
tutoring, one-to-30.
The average tutorial student is
two sigmas better than the
group students.
In other words, the average
tutorial student is at the
98th percentile of the ordinary
teaching group.
So the question is--
the natural question is, how can
we make group instruction
as effective as tutorial
instruction?
As Benjamin Bloom says, he says,
finding such methods
would be an educational
contribution of
the greatest magnitude.
Because, for example,
it would change our
notions about human potential.
We'd actually realize, oh,
actually, there's not that
much innate in what
people can do.
Most of it is how well they've
learned, how well
they've been taught.
So the great question--
and it's the title of Bloom's
paper-- is the search for
methods of group instruction
as effective
as one-to-one tutoring.
To that end, let's think about
the following question, which
is, what makes tutoring
so effective?
So I'm going to ask you that,
to consider that question in
groups of two and three,
whatever's sort of convenient
in your region of the room.
So, what makes tutoring
so effective?
After you discuss, we'll take
reasons, put them on the
board, and then I'll show you
methods of group instruction
that may not quite get us all
the way to tutoring, but that
answer many of the good
characteristics of tutoring
and bring them into
group instruction.
OK, so please find one
or two neighbors.
Introduce yourselves.
You never know.
You might find a teaching
colleague.
And think about what makes
tutoring so effective.
OK, so take 30 seconds
and collect
your thoughts together.
OK, who would like to suggest
something that your group
thought of?
You don't necessarily have to
believe it, just something you
discussed and think
we should share.
Yes?
Could you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Elena.
PROFESSOR: Elena.
AUDIENCE: For one-on-one
tutoring, I imagine there's
less time for misconceptions
to get
ingrained in your brain.
PROFESSOR: OK, you can nip
misconceptions in the bud.
Whereas in, for example, group
instruction, you may not even
know the students have
a misconception
until the final exam.
Then what do you do?
OK, let's see.
This group, could you
tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: So we thought--
PROFESSOR: Could you
tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Eric.
PROFESSOR: Eric.
AUDIENCE: We thought in a group,
there's probably a lot
of just dissemination
of information.
And in one-on-one tutoring, it's
probably not one person
just telling person two
a bunch of stuff.
It's going through
exam problems.
PROFESSOR: Right, OK.
So the contrast in this is
what does the teaching
situation look like?
In a typical lecture, someone
may just talk at you for 50
minutes, whereas it's hard to
imagine a one-on-one tutorial
situation where you walk in for
your tutorial, and they
just talk at you
for 50 minutes.
That would seem so odd and so
counter to all conventions of
human discussion.
It would take a really, really
disciplined and well-trained
person to sit still for 50
minutes for that kind of
treatment, so not initially a
good kind of training either.
OK, so I'll say you cannot
yammer at the audience for 50
minutes straight.
Yes, can you tell
me your name?
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: Could you
tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: I'm Whitney.
PROFESSOR: Whitney
AUDIENCE: I think it follows
from this discussion that
arises between two people that
the student experiences
validation of what they've
understood, and it helps build
their confidence.
PROFESSOR: OK, because they're
talking in a small group, so
they can get validation
in a safe setting.
Is that?
OK, so it's safe.
It's a safe setting for raising
ideas maybe that
you're not sure about.
OK, there was one more.
Yeah, can you tell
me your name?
AUDIENCE: Martin.
PROFESSOR: Martin.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
With tutoring, it's much easier
to identify exactly
what the student has trouble
understanding, and then tailor
the teaching according
to that.
PROFESSOR: OK, so you can tailor
the teaching according
to what you find out.
So sort of like the new
electronic SATs.
According to what you don't
know or do know, in each
question, they give you
questions based on your
previous answers at the right
level of difficulty.
So you can tailor.
Yeah, can you tell
me your name?
AUDIENCE: Azrael.
PROFESSOR: Azrael, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think related to
this, it's very valuable to be
able to tailor your teaching
style to the student
[INAUDIBLE]
in general, not just specific
points [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, you can
tailor the teaching
style to the student.
If, for example, the
student is--
for example, suppose you're
teaching math to somebody
who's an architect.
Well, you can use lots of
examples that are particular
to something they're totally
fascinated by.
You can tailor a teaching
method.
OK, let me get something from
somewhere back there, in case
I've been neglecting people
way in the back.
Oh, go ahead.
You guys had your chance.
I'll be back.
Can you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Graham.
PROFESSOR: Graham.
AUDIENCE: Just the level of
engagement, it is impossible
to sit there in a one-on-one
setting and think about the
music you like [INAUDIBLE]
the subject matter at hand.
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK, so the level of engagement
is much higher in a tutorial.
So that's the complement
of this one.
So the student engagement
is much higher.
Yeah, just as it's hard for a
teacher in a tutorial setting
to just talk for 50 minutes
straight, it's also hard for a
student in a tutorial session to
surf the web for 50 minutes
straight, or use their
BlackBerry or read the
newspaper or whatever it may be
that the standard methods
of lecture distraction are.
Yes, can you tell
me your name?
AUDIENCE: Question about
the conditions in these
experiments.
So normally in a university
setting in this country,
tutoring is something that
students seek out for
themselves.
It's not something that's
provided in lieu of lecture.
Was that the case in this?
Was it really just that the same
material was covered in
the same semester and they
just did it two different
ways, and everybody had
to go to tutoring?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so what
they did was--
I don't think these were
university students.
I think these were high
school and even
grade school students.
Yeah.
But what they did was they
took the same number of
teaching hours, and they either
taught them in lecture
or they taught them in
tutorials, one-on-one, or I
think sometimes one-on-two.
AUDIENCE: So in both cases, they
were required to go to
class, in a sense.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I mean, I don't know
if they actually
went to the big class.
But I'm sure they went to
the tutorial class.
That's partly of one
of the differences.
That's number six.
Yes, way in the back.
AUDIENCE: From experience,
I've found that you know
students don't understand
something.
You don't why until
you sit down.
Usually you find there's some
gaping hole that's quite often
easily plugged.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And how do you find that out?
AUDIENCE: You start asking them,
what class did you have?
What did you not understand?
And sometimes they'll just
bubble [? right out, ?]
I never got this one
key concept.
PROFESSOR: OK, so you can ask
them questions, specific
questions to figure out what
they don't know, to diagnose
what they're confused about.
OK, let's take one more, and
then I'll show you some
methods that hopefully address
what these characteristics--
these missing characteristics
of group instruction.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: On one-on-one
tutoring, for the student who
might not be as into the effort
[INAUDIBLE] added
pressure, just feeling that
there are other people
[INAUDIBLE]
student, there's no feeling of
why I need to learn much more,
[INAUDIBLE].
You don't really prepare
yourself for anyone else.
PROFESSOR: Right, so the
method of teaching
automatically adjusts to
whatever level the student is.
So they're not comparing
to other people.
They're are actually just
comparing to what they don't
know right then.
So let's just call it intrinsic
comparison with the
knowledge, rather than extrinsic
with other students.
OK, so there's less emotional
churn as a result of that.
OK, so we could continue
this list, but this is
an excellent start.
So now, if we look through that
list, there's several
themes that come out.
I mean, it's hard in a group
setting to figure out what
students don't know.
It's hard to ask
them questions.
It's hard to keep
people engaged.
It's easy to just talk at
people as a teacher.
So what can we do in group
teaching to capture as many
characteristics of
this as we can?
Well, I'll show you methods that
I divide into four time
scales, ranging from
short to long.
But before I do that, let me ask
if there are any questions
on anything so far.
OK.
You were first.
AUDIENCE: How is student
achievement measured?
Is it just test scores?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that
was a test score.
So what they did is, actually
they gave them a test.
Like, if it was algebra, they
gave them an algebra test, and
then tested them at the end, and
at the beginning too, just
to see where they were
to start with.
AUDIENCE: So were the lectures
more tailored to just teaching
them algebra, and the tutoring
was specifically tailored to
doing problems in algebra?
PROFESSOR: Well, the tutoring
was whatever they needed to do
well on the test.
And the lecturing was hopefully
designed that way too.
But it had all the flaws of, you
want to teach so students
will do well on your
final exam.
But what do you do
when you have 30
diverse students in there?
You had a question too.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
do we know which of
these particular suggestions
are the most important, and
which ones might be good?
PROFESSOR: We have some idea.
Good question.
The question is which of these
is most important, and which
is less important.
Actually, they're all getting
at something similar.
But there's a middle group in
there, actually, that they
studied, which was
mastery learning.
So mastery learning, it's just
like a programmed instruction.
So the idea is that--
Keller Plan is another
word for it.
So mastery learning is midway
between tutoring and group
instruction.
There was one sigma better,
so 84th percentile.
So mastery learning, you don't
go on to the new topics until
you pass the mastery exam
on the previous topic.
So you're always building
on a solid foundation.
And so you work until you can
pass the exam, and then you
continue on.
And just by adding that to group
instruction, you get one
sigma better.
So right away, diagnosing
misconceptions, you can see,
is quite important.
But there's still another
one sigma to get.
And so that's, I think,
what all the rest of
these items are about.
And we do know a lot of stuff
about how people learn.
One of it is questions.
Questions are essential.
So I'm going to talk
about that.
But let me just ask again,
any questions?
OK, good.
This time it worked.
So now, what did I do?
So this is actually
the first method.
So how long did I wait after
I said, any questions?
Half a second?
One minute?
No, five seconds.
So the first time, I didn't
wait five seconds, because
actually a question came up a
little before five seconds.
But this time, the second time,
I waited five seconds.
Now, why is that?
So that is the first method.
When you ask a question--
for example, "any questions"
or "what do you think about
this"-- wait five seconds.
And I'll explain why
in a second.
But, methods shortest
to longest.
The reason I divide them by
shortest to longest is the
shortest ones are
the easiest to
incorporate into your teaching.
So anytime you teach, if you
ask a question, wait five
seconds, so the five-second
time scale.
OK, so why do I wait
five seconds,
and why not two seconds?
Well, the reason is, think
about your audience.
Suppose you're talking away at
them, and all the sudden you
ask a question.
Now, what are they hearing?
So everyone's seen
Charlie Brown?
So what does Charlie Brown hear
when he goes to school?
Wah wah wah wah wah wah wah wah
wah wah wah wah, and all
of a sudden that changes
and there's a question.
It takes about a second to
realize that the wah wah wah
has stopped, and you're being
asked a question.
OK, so one second's gone.
Let's call it that, the
thumb-- one second.
Now, it takes about another
second to even figure out what
the question is.
Now you say, oh yeah, there's
a question being asked.
What did they say?
OK, maybe now let's say it's
one and a half seconds.
So now we're at somewhere
between two and three seconds.
Now it takes maybe one or two
more seconds to figure out
what you're going to
say about that.
Do I have any thoughts
about it?
Do I actually have
any questions?
Do I have a thought about the
thing they're asking me?
Do I know what the band gap is
in silicon, whatever the
question may be?
So now we're somewhere between
four, maybe near five seconds.
And then it maybe takes another
second to get the
courage up to raise your hand
and be ready with a sentence.
So now we're at least
five seconds.
So if you don't wait those five
seconds, what you'll get
is, you'll be getting a few
questions, but you'll get
questions from people who
already thought about the
material, in other words, the
people who are already at the
98th percentile.
But if you want to bring
everybody in, and get
everybody thinking about it,
you really need to wait, so
you don't get questions just
from the usual suspects.
So wait five seconds.
Now, the mechanism is
quite important.
If you just say, OK I'm going
to wait five seconds, you'll
go, any questions.
Oh, done, five seconds is up.
And you'll think five seconds
is up in about one second.
And why is that?
Well, you're up in front of a
whole bunch of people, and the
adrenaline will be flowing.
And adrenaline speeds
up your time sense.
All those stories about people
who-- like mothers who saw
their kid about to get hit by
the car, they race out and
grab the kid and the
car keeps going.
Maybe it screeches to a stop.
They've managed to
rescue their kid.
Well, they could act much faster
because adrenaline
makes the time sense
much sharper.
So your idea of five seconds
will be more like one second.
There's another reason, which is
there's this mistaken idea
that if you're not talking,
you're not teaching.
So you're being paid to teach.
And oh my god, you're
not saying anything.
That means you must not
know something.
So you feel insecure, and that
increases the adrenaline and
only speeds up the time
problem more.
So to wait five seconds, you
actually have to count it --
one 1,000, two 1,000, three
1,000, four 1,000, five 1,000.
And I actually sometimes just
do it behind my back with my
hand-- one 1,000, two
1,000, three 1,000,
four 1,000, five 1,000.
And it's not like you have to
be watching the audience for
the whole five seconds.
It's actually better to wait
the whole five seconds, and
then choose one of the hands
that has gone up rather than
the first hand that goes
up at two seconds.
You say, oh, thank god, somebody
asked a question.
OK, now my waiting is over.
Well, again, you'll be back
in the usual suspect soup.
So, first time scale for
bringing in questions, in
other words, spreading the
engagement through the class.
Because when people are asking
questions, they're by
definition engaged.
They're struggling with
the material.
They're trying to make
it their own.
Wait five seconds.
OK, the next method.
So the next method is short
time scale, one minute.
And that is to use a feedback
sheet at the end of every
teaching session.
So you actually have an example
of a feedback sheet
that we'll ask you to fill out
at the end of this session,
which we handed out
at the beginning.
And the blank versions of that
sheet will also be on the TLL
website, so you can actually
download it, print it, and use
it in your own teaching,
as well as my notes
on how to use it.
But the main point is that at
the end of the class, you give
the students one or two
minutes to fill
out a feedback sheet.
And what I've converged on is
the following three questions
on my feedback sheet, which is,
what was most confusing?
Basically, what question
you have that
still wasn't answered.
Second question is, what was
the most useful or most
useless example or demonstration
or teaching
method that happened today?
And the third question is,
any other comments?
So now let me explain why I
use those three questions.
The first question, these sheets
are all anonymous.
And it's a chance for someone,
if they felt a little bit shy
asking questions in front of
people-- so here in the
tutorial, one of the
characteristics that was
mentioned was that you don't
feel nervous about asking a
question, because there's no
one there, or maybe there's
one other person there.
Whereas in a class of
30 or 80 or 20, you
may feel a bit nervous.
Well, if you feel a bit nervous,
you just put your
question on the feedback
sheet.
And so then at the beginning of
the next session, I answer
all the questions on the
feedback sheets.
So it takes me more than one
minute, but actually not that
much longer.
Because you could
flip through 100
sheets in about 10 minutes.
You just glance through.
You'll see a bunch of questions
are repeated.
And you'll say, oh yeah, I do
really need to explain that.
And at the beginning in the next
session, just explain all
the important points.
And that has another benefit,
which is that it links back to
the previous lecture, or the
previous teaching session.
So now you've made a thread
between the previous session
and the current one, and you got
everyone up to speed into
the space where you
want them to be.
So that's why I use the
first question.
The second question
is, what worked?
What didn't work?
And I also had to add, and tell
me whether it worked or
didn't work.
Because I used to get examples
saying, that example.
And I didn't know whether they
loved it or hated it.
So then I said, please
tell me the sign of
the effect as well.
And then I would know.
I would start to build a model
of how students think and what
works for them.
So every time, basically, I
learned that I brought in a
demonstration, there
was universal love
on the second question.
So I said, OK, that really
connects with students.
And I would make sure
to do more of that.
So it was reinforcement for me
and practice for me at being a
better teacher.
And what you'll find is that as
you use the sheet more and
more, you get better and better
at predicting how
students think.
So for example, you're doing
some discussion on the board,
some examples on derivation.
And the first time you do it,
maybe you don't know it's not
going to go well.
And then you read the sheet and
you see, oh my god, I was
a disaster.
30 questions out of 80 all said,
I didn't understand x.
So now you understand that
students didn't understand the
way you did it.
Well, now you've built
a better model of
how students think.
So next time you're doing a
derivation, what you'll find
is-- at least what I've found
is in the middle of the
derivation, I'll realize, oh,
this is not going well.
I'm going to get a
lot of questions
about this on the sheet.
Oops, but it's to late.
I'm in the middle of the soup.
I can't un-drink the soup.
So I just finish the soup and
just wait for the questions.
But then after maybe another
week of using the sheet, you
actually have quite a good
model of the students.
And now before you start the
derivation or when you're
planning the lecture, you
realize, oh yeah, that's not
going to go well.
Let me do it the other
way, because I
know that works better.
So you'll find your model of the
students developing more
and more refinements and
more and more accuracy.
In other words, you're becoming
a more expert teacher.
And then the third question
on the sheet
is, any other comments?
The reason for that is, it's
just a free-form space.
And I've actually had students
say, oh, actually, when you
explained that thing, you
actually explained it wrong.
I was like, oh that's
good to know.
So then in the beginning
of the--
because we did it properly in
this other class, and here's
the exact reference that you
maybe didn't know about.
I was like, oh great.
So at the beginning of the next
class, I say, hey, one of
you guys pointed out a mistake
I made, and here is the
corrected version.
And people might not be
willing to say that
personally, because they say,
oh my god, I don't want to
correct the professor and
make them feel stupid.
But it's much easier to do
it on an anonymous sheet.
So I get really useful
information on that.
And sometimes you can figure out
who did it, so you could
send an email saying, oh thanks,
that was useful.
All right.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And it is.
So you may think, oh no, you
don't want to be corrected.
But actually, after you tell
the students the following
enough, so it's again
back to this.
In a group, students feel like,
oh my god, I don't want
to make a mistake.
So I give them the following
speech quite often.
Because if you don't
make mistakes--
I tell them, look, how
much did you know
when you were born?
Not a hell of a lot.
You couldn't talk.
You couldn't hardly walk.
Well, how do you learn stuff?
Did you just all the sudden
start walking and talking?
No.
You mangled your grammar.
You put "-ed" at the end of
every past participle, even
though some don't have that.
And eventually you sorted it
all out and you stood up
straight and you walked.
So basically, how
did you learn?
By making mistakes.
So the only way to learn
is to make mistakes.
So if you don't make any
mistakes, you will learn--
you'll know as much at the start
of your class as at the
end of the class.
So you want to make mistakes.
So I tell them that
a bunch of times.
But if then I'm really
embarrassed about making
mistakes, then I've defeated the
whole purpose of telling
students that.
So I actually thank them
whenever they point out
something that I didn't
do right.
OK, so that's the second
time scale.
Now, the third time scale
is not that much longer.
It's about, let's say,
four or five minutes.
And it's a question which I'll
call a conceptual multiple
choice question.
And I'll give you an example.
OK, so here is the question
that I'll use
to illustrate it.
Here is a pyramid with
a square base.
And it's B by B. The length of
one side of the base is B. And
the perpendicular height of
the pyramid is H. OK, so
what's the volume?
OK, so does everyone understand
the question?
OK.
Give it a try.
Find your group or one or two.
Any questions--
any confusions about
the question?
Don't give me any answers just
yet, but any confusions about
the question?
OK, so find your groups of one
or two other people, and we'll
discuss that question
in a couple minutes.
Anyone want to say anything
about this?
Is there a section I
haven't heard from?
Yeah, go ahead.
Can you just say your name?
AUDIENCE: Brian.
PROFESSOR: Brian, OK.
So you like D but
not the others?
OK, can you tell me, for
example, why you don't like A?
AUDIENCE: Well, because all of
them just have the wrong
proportionality.
If B increases, then the square
is going to increase in
area as B squared--
PROFESSOR: Ah, so you would
like that to B squared.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Whereas it's just a
single B and a single H. OK,
so you don't like that because
the proportionality is wrong.
It doesn't scale correctly.
So let me put here,
bad scaling.
What was another problem?
AUDIENCE: It also has
the wrong units.
PROFESSOR: It has bogus units.
OK, so it has bogus
dimensions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, they're pretty
much interchangeable.
I use units to mean meters
or feet or something, and
dimensions to be things
like length.
But they're pretty much
interchangeable in usage.
So bad scaling, bad
dimensions.
OK, anyone have any
comments about B?
AUDIENCE: Same.
PROFESSOR: Same problem.
In fact, it's even
more horrendous.
Well, it starts out OK, I
mean, at least as far as
dimensions are concerned.
But then what does it do?
This has the wrong dimensions.
That has the right dimensions,
and then you add them.
That's terrible.
OK, so the dimensions
are just bogus.
Ah, OK.
Can anyone say anything
about choice C?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you look at the
extremes, like if you make H
very small--
PROFESSOR: So if you stop on
this pyramid and step on it
until H goes to 0, what happens
to the volume here?
It goes to infinity.
Yeah, it's terrible.
So the extreme cases
are just bogus.
So it fails that test.
OK, now we're back to
D. So who likes D?
So we have a few people
who like D.
[STUDENT CALLS OUT]
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK, go ahead.
You don't like D.
AUDIENCE: No, I don't like D.
PROFESSOR: OK, why not?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: It's the volume of
the box, which has a size
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this is the volume
of a box, in other
words, if I had vertical
sides.
So let me draw vertical
sides here.
Right, so whereas the pyramid
has actually got to be less.
Now, it's kind of mysterious
what this factor here should
be, but it's definitely
less than 1.
So this is comparison
with a box.
So it has a good properties,
and it's a good answer.
It's just not correct.
But that's OK, because it's
important to realize what's
good about it and what's
not good about it.
So it satisfies the
extreme cases.
It satisfies dimensions.
It scales correctly.
Like you pointed out, you want
B squared, because it's the
area down there.
So it's good.
It's not all good.
Let's call it good mostly.
But as they say, a miss is as
good as a mile except in
horseshoes and atom bombs.
So good mostly, but
box comparison.
OK, so let me cross this guy
out and this guy out
and that guy out.
So what do you conclude
from that?
They're all wrong.
So here's another multiple
choice question.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK, so
who votes for A?
One of these is definitely
correct.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: No votes for A?
Who votes for B?
Oh, I'm hurt.
I'm hurt.
Well, B is in fact correct.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So every once in a
while, I throw the students a
curve ball and make all
the choices wrong.
Now, why would I do that, such
an evil, dastardly thing?
Well, it's good every once
in a while to do that.
In fact, I found that out
experimentally, because the
first time I used this question
with the students, I
was already using the
feedback sheets.
And on the feedback sheets, I
got back tons of love on the
comment sheets.
The students said, oh,
we love that, having
all the answers wrong.
Don't do it too often, but do
it every once in a while,
maybe once a month or so.
And that way, they never know
when it's coming, so they
always have to check
all the answers.
They can't just do everything
by elimination.
So it is a very useful
thing to do.
There are other reasons for it
too, and if you're curious,
ask me in the questions,
and I'll explain more
reasons to do it.
But that's already a
sufficient reason.
OK, so that's method three.
And you see you get a
bit of discussion.
You get multiple choices.
And what does that allow
you to do right away?
Well, what was one
of the problems?
Is, you can find out
what misconception
students have early.
Point one up there, in
a tutorial, you can
ask students questions.
Well, why not ask some
questions in
a big lecture too?
So that's what we just did.
So you can find out.
If 90% of the students get it
like that, you know you don't
have to say much more
about the topic.
But if the answers are
distributed at the monkey
line, 25% for all the answers,
then you know there's going to
be trouble.
And it's worth actually
expanding on this point and
the theme that question gets
across right then in lecture.
So you could make it much more
tailored to the group of
students you have.
And the students also--
what happens in their
small groups?
Right, so remember we mentioned
that in a tutorial,
that it's a safe setting for
raising questions, whereas a
big group might not be.
Well, what have we done by
letting everyone work in
groups of two or three?
We've created a whole bunch of
safe settings for questions.
So the students are free
to discuss in their
groups of two or three.
And if they can't resolve it
there, well then they feel
pretty confident that it's
worthwhile sharing it with the
whole class.
Maybe the whole class
can learn something
from that as well.
And that has another benefit,
which is that it gets around
the gender imbalance.
So to illustrate this problem,
I was once in a
bookstore in New York.
And I was standing in the
computer section and this
couple walked up the stairs.
And the woman asked the
man, oh, there's some
big fat book on Java.
And she said, what's Java?
And within a millisecond, not
batting an eyelid, he said,
oh, it's the fastest search
engine on the internet, which
is completely rubbish.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: It's a programming
language.
So it has absolutely nothing
to do with a search engine.
I'm sure no search engine
is even written in Java.
So it has nothing to do
with search engines.
So it's a complete lie.
But he said it so fast.
So there's a dichotomy there,
which is-- generally speaking,
it's called actually male
answer syndrome.
And the women--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: I see all the women
laughing, or I hear all the
women laughing.
Well, what you'll find is
generally, men are very
willing to talk about stuff
they know nothing about,
speaking crudely in extreme
caricatures, whereas women are
reluctant to talk about stuff
they even know about.
So if you just ask a question to
a group just flat out, even
with the five-second wait,
you're more likely to get
responses from the guys
than from the girls.
So the way to try to mitigate
that imbalance is to give
people, first, a safe setting
for asking questions.
And then people actually
calibrate to the correct level
about, well, is this
a reasonable idea?
Is this not a reasonable idea?
Could the people around me
have good ideas about it?
Is it resolved now?
If
Not, well, it's probably safe to
raise in a bigger setting.
So you'll actually fix the
gender imbalance to a large
extent, and balance it out.
So it has lots of benefits
that you get
from tutorial teaching.
So now I'll show you the last
one, which we won't actually
do for half an hour.
But I want to sketch out how
you could do a question for
half an hour.
I'll show you the kind of
question that works in that
time frame.
So this could be multiple
choice.
Doesn't have to be, but some
kind of conceptual question
with lots of discussion.
And often, it may have
a demonstration.
So let me show you that
particular question.
So I'm going to use--
I have these guys too, but I
also have the wood blocks
which I like so much.
So here are two wood blocks cut
for me by the machine shop
of the Cambridge physics
department
when I taught there.
So they cut them out of the
same piece of pine, same
grain, direction, everything.
The only difference is this is
2 centimeters thick, and
that's 1 centimeter thick.
But They're both a foot long
and 5 centimeters wide.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to tap this block, and
you'll hear a note.
[TAPS A NOTE ON WOOD BLOCK]
PROFESSOR: Did everyone
hear the note?
Great.
OK, so now the question is, when
I tap this block, is the
note going to be higher, the
same frequency, or lower?
OK, so does everyone understand
the question?
OK, so discuss with
your neighbors.
We'll take a vote in about
a couple minutes.
I won't give you the 10 minutes
I would normally give
people to discuss and argue.
We'll take a couple reasons,
then we'll do the experiment.
OK, time to vote.
So, just to sketch out how this
could actually turn into
a 30-minute question, normally I
give students about a couple
minutes to think on their own,
then take a vote, and then set
everyone to argue
with each other.
I say, in particular, find
someone who has a different
answer than you, and try to
convince them of your answer.
So then you get a big
argument going.
And so then I let that go
for about 10 minutes.
And then we take another vote.
And then we discuss.
So let's just imagine we've
skipped forward to the end of
the group discussion,
and we're going to
take the second vote.
So who thinks the thick block
will have a higher frequency
than the thin block?
About maybe 20 people.
Who thinks they'll be equal?
About 25.
Who thinks the thick block will
have a lower frequency?
About 50.
OK, so we have a good spread
of opinion there.
So now, again, in the scenario
of the 30-minute question, I
would ask for reasons, just like
I did here, and I would
just be the scribe.
I would just write down people's
reasons for A, B, or
C, for greater, equal,
or less than.
Just make sure I understand
the reason and
then write it down.
I don't have to agree
with the reason.
Just make sure I understand it,
and the person who says it
says, yeah, that's what
I'm trying to say.
Write it on the board.
Then give people the opportunity
to say a reason
for any of the others or
against any of them, or
comment on any reason already
on the board.
And that can go for another
10 minutes or so,
sometimes even longer.
And then I ask people, OK, the
test of science is experiment.
Should we do the experiment?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So just to remind you
of the earlier tone.
[TAPS A NOTE ON WOOD BLOCK]
[TAPS A HIGHER NOTE
ON WOOD BLOCK]
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So the
ayes have it.
OK, so it turns out to be
roughly almost a factor of two
higher in frequency, almost
a full octave.
It's not quite.
If they were infinitely thin,
and this were twice infinitely
thin, it would be exactly
a factor of two.
But because they have
a finite thickness,
it's not quite true.
But that's how xylophones
work.
In fact, many people have
reasoned their way to the
correct answer by thinking
about xylophones.
And many people have reasoned
their way to the incorrect
answer by thinking about guitar
strings, which brings
up a very interesting discussion
you can have.
So what did you notice
about here?
When I was about to tap
the second one, could
you hear a pin drop?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Right.
Student engagement
is much higher,
because people are involved.
But the act of voting commits
people to a public view.
And they want to know, is this
right or is this not right?
And the act of voting has
another benefit, which is that
you get a much better
error signal.
Whereas, suppose you
didn't vote.
And suppose you thought, well,
it could be higher because
it's stiffer.
On the other hand, it's bigger
wavelengths, so it's lower.
And you sort of both reasons
in your head.
You're in a superposition
state.
And then the experiment
happens--
bing bing bing-- and it's
higher, and you say, oh yeah,
I knew that.
It was higher because it's
thicker and stiffer.
So you think actually you
understood everything, but you
didn't actually figure out,
well, which of these two
reasons is right and why?
Whereas if you have to publicly
commit to one answer,
then you get a clearly defined
signal back about whether that
answer was right or not.
So it's very important to
make sure people vote.
And at the same time, it's very
important to make sure
people are not punished
for voting.
So does it matter in my classes
whether people get the
vote right or not?
I just want them to vote.
And so then I have to give my
speech about, it's better to
be wrong than right.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So I've been in lots
of classes where the professor
asks a question and waits a
few seconds for people to
raise their hands.
And by the time he's done or
she's done, there's a third of
the class raising their hand,
and those the people who had
their hands up first.
So how do you actually
take that step?
PROFESSOR: Sorry, could you tell
me what they're doing?
They ask a question.
AUDIENCE: They ask
a question--
PROFESSOR: Do they let the
whole class discuss it?
AUDIENCE: Not necessarily.
So that's what you're
saying is key here?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's
really key to let
the whole class discuss--
so the normal structure for a
long question like this one
I'll do is I'll make
sure everyone
understands the question.
And then I'll let people think
by themselves for a minute or
two, and take a vote after that,
a straw poll, I call it,
so people don't feel
it's too weighty.
The reason for that is
that people have
different learning styles.
And some people want to think
longer for themself, and some
people want to just start
talking right away, so I want
to give something
for everybody.
And then after I take that vote,
that gives me an idea
where the class is, and it gives
the class an idea of
where they are, and who
has different views.
And then they can start arguing
with each other.
And so now they've had a lot of
time to actually check what
they all think.
So people will have had
arguments in their group that
they can't resolve, so they're
very eager to actually share
the argument.
Whereas if you just ask the
question without giving people
time to struggle with it, you're
basically wasting the
effect of the question.
AUDIENCE: So how do you decide
what level of difficulty for
discussion?
PROFESSOR: This is
a hard question.
But it's so rich.
It has so many things.
I don't expect most people to
get the question right.
In fact, when I ask this to
faculty in physics department,
when I give physics teaching
seminars, most
people get it wrong.
I won't say all the places where
that's been true, but
it's been at many universities
around the world.
So I don't expect
people to get it
right, and I don't care.
The reason for it is that it
introduces so many ideas--
about, for example, spring
models of solids.
We can use musical instruments
as analogies--
that I think it's worth
spending even a
whole class on it.
And in fact, one time somebody
said, well, but a xylophone,
all the things are the
same thickness and
they're just longer.
How does that work?
And I said, oh, I'm glad
you asked that.
And I pulled out my daughter's
xylophone--
she has a baby xylophone--
from my backpack.
And so we analyzed the xylophone
right there.
So it leads to so many
interesting things that I'm
willing to spend a whole
class on it.
So that's how I decide
how much time
to allocate to something.
If it's a really core idea,
spend more time on it.
And if it's peripheral, tend to
spend less time on it or do
a really short question
on it, if at all.
And then the difficulty--
I like to get questions,
ideally--
I mean, this one's different
just because it's so rich--
but ideally where students are
sort of at 60% correct
thinking by themself,
maybe 65%, even 70%.
Because even though they may be
right, that sounds like oh,
they're mostly fine,
but they may not
know why they're right.
So then in the discussion they
can solidify their reasons and
maybe get up to 80% or 90%.
Whereas if you've got a question
where they're 30%
correct to start with, and
that doesn't have other
redeeming qualities like the
richness of it, you'll just
propagate noise throughout the
system, and just basically
wrong ideas will just spread all
over and you'll spend all
your time correcting those.
So I gauge the difficulty
based on
trying to hit that mark.
OK, so hopefully you've
seen, first of all,
that tutorial teaching--
the main points from today--
is much more effective than
regular teaching as normally
practiced because of these
characteristics--
generally questioning, feedback,
instant feedback and
corrective feedback
right away.
But through a series of methods,
you can bring many of
the benefits of tutorial
teaching to your own large
group teaching, which is the
kind of teaching that most of
us will do, just for
cost reasons.
So I wish you best of luck
in all your teaching.
AUDIENCE: Can I just [? get ?]
one interesting statement?
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: It's something to
think about, and faculty often
have difficulty with this.
There's probably a pretty high
correlation between the amount
of information that you want
to get through to students,
and the time that it
takes to do it.
The more questions you ask, the
less you can get through
the material.
And this constant
questioning--
PROFESSOR: This constant
battle.
AUDIENCE: What should I do?
Should I just try to get this
much information because I
want to ask lots of questions?
Or do I want to get that much
information through, then I
better not spend too much
time asking questions?
It's a conundrum.
I think asking questions is
just a phenomenal way of
learning, but [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, basically
we teach too much stuff.
And that's the fundamental
problem.
And so one solution to that is
to say, look, all the details,
get it from a book.
And in class, we're going to
do what you can't easily do
from the book, which is
struggle, argue, reason, and
correct those reasons.
That's hard to do from a book.
So you should use the class
time for something that's
value added that you
can't do elsewhere.
So good luck with that.
Please take a minute to fill
out the feedback sheets.
And as long as no one kicks us
out, I'll be here as long as
people have questions.
[? COMPUTER: Answers ?]
from lecture seven to questions
generated in lecture six.
PROFESSOR: OK, so questions
from before.
What are your suggestions for
someone teaching a course that
they are not expert in at all,
you know, for the first time?
So I'm a practical man.
I know most people, when they're
teaching a course,
teaching is not going
to be their life.
I mean, it is for me,
but that's unusual.
And if you love teaching,
that's great.
But probably, your job will be
dependent on how much research
you do or other activities like
department committees.
And so you don't want to destroy
your whole career on
your first course.
By which I mean, just try to
survive your first course.
Because what you could do the
first time you're teaching
it-- so the answer
is, you need to
somehow become an expert.
If you want to teach it
differently and creatively and
interestingly, you somehow
need to become an expert.
Now, you could do that by
spending the whole summer
before really figuring out the
material from scratch.
And that probably in the long
term is a good thing.
You'd probably find useful
results in your
research from it.
But probably you don't have
that summer to do that.
And so what you need to do is
kill two birds with one stone
and become an expert by teaching
it, in which case the
best plan I would recommend is
just to teach it pretty much
the regular way, with some
interactive changes in lecture.
But just follow the regular
plan, as much as it sticks in
one's craw.
Because in doing that, first
of all, you will
be rocking the boat.
So people will accept it
even if it's not great.
And you'll become an
expert by the end.
And then the next time you
teach it, you'll be OK.
Then you you've done that summer
of thinking, but you've
done it during the class.
So it meant the first class
didn't go as well as it could.
But it also meant you survived
and you could order material
for your lab and all the
other things that
you'd do in the summer.
How do you--
so I like it when you emphasize
that it's OK to get
the wrong answer.
It's like with the wood blocks,
I mentioned how,
mostly when I ask this of
physics professors too, people
get it mostly wrong.
And so I had another example of
that in Colorado, because I
gave a talk using
the wood blocks.
So how can you incorporate that
"it's OK to be wrong, as
long as you learn" attitude
into class?
One of the best ways is to
minimize the amount of
grading, and the emphasis
given to grading.
Grading, basically, as a
first approximation--
so if I just add two letters,
it's hard to avoid that.
So grading, when you mark
someone and you tell them,
bad, A B, C, D, well, the people
who are getting B's,
C's, and D's, whatever the quote
bad grades are, you are
actually shaming people.
And in some ways, you are
degrading their psyche.
So it's not healthy.
So that is one of the political
barriers to
educational change
is the importance
that we give to grading.
And I will talk about that
in the final session.
You may think, oh what about
the people who get A's?
Well, if you're giving A,
B, C's, and D's, the
people who get A's.
They may have struggled and were
thinking, oh my god, will
I get an A?
Will I get an A?
Then they get an A.
So they go, phew.
But still, they were nervous
about their learning the whole
time instead of enjoying it
as much as they could.
And second, there's also
studies, many studies, which
show that when you reward people
for things they already
enjoy-- this is totally
fascinating--
so when you reward people for
things they already enjoy
doing, their enjoyment drops.
So if you start paying people
for things that they would
like doing anyway, then they
don't like it as much.
And you [INAUDIBLE] everyday
examples of this.
You know if you know anyone
who's a symphony orchestra
player, they say, oh yeah, the
best way to start hating music
is to be a professional
musician.
They love music, and then they
had to do it for pay, in all
of a sudden they don't like as
much anymore, not all of a
sudden, but slowly.
So there are many, many
studies about that--
motivation.
So what you want to do really
is to find intrinsic
motivation.
And so the difference between
extrinsic and intrinsic
motivation is fundamental.
And what you want to try to do
is create the environment
always where the motivation
is intrinsic, so that the
questions are interesting.
So what that means is you
don't want to use bad
questions that people don't have
an interest in, and then
force them to be interested
because you give them
extrinsic motivation.
That's a fundamental bad choice,
and then it's being
solved with the fundamental
wrong approach.
What do you need to do is rather
than do both of those,
you say, OK, let me find
interesting questions that
people care about.
And then the intrinsic
motivation carries people
through, whether they're
right or wrong.
So that's why I like questions
like the wood block so much,
because people are just
actually interested.
They want to know.
They say, oh, that's
a good question.
I should know that.
Oh, maybe I don't.
OK, well maybe I'll
learn something.
So the other part of that is,
if you notice, I didn't use
clickers when we did
this question.
Partly, it's because clickers
are expensive and you have a
bunch of logistics to do, and
then you need probably some
ludicrous Windows program to
receive the signals, and I
haven't written the Linux
version for it.
So there's all of
those issues.
Those are, I would say, not
the fundamental issue.
The fundamental issue with
clickers, why I don't like
them, is that they make people
think they're being spied on.
So even especially if you live
in a surveillance society,
where actually all your phone
calls are being spied on,
people might think, well when
you have clickers, you're
being spied on to know whether
you got the right answer or
not, and it's going to count
against you at some point.
So I'm very happy with people
to just raise their hands.
And that's, in a way, more
anonymous than a clicker that
belongs to you.
So there are ways of getting
around that with clickers.
You can to have people trade
clickers so they know that the
clickers are random.
So you can do things
like that.
But still, I like the informal
feel of, yeah,
just raise your hand.
Don't worry.
It's a safe space in
the classroom.
And I have to say that
a few times.
But just raise your hand,
and don't worry.
And I'm not spying on you.
I don't care whether you get
the right answer or not.
For example, with the wood
blocks, I expect most people
to get the wrong answer.
That's OK.
We'll learn something
about it afterwards.
So you do have to work at it,
but there are things you can
do to keep the class
[? safe. ?]
There are also things to do,
which is that never--
it's hard to remember how much
power you have as the
instructor, and just
as someone in
a position of authority.
So I might have told you the
story from when I was a
graduate student, but it's
worth telling again, if I
haven't, which is that I was
giving a talk in a group
meeting when I was a
graduate student.
My adviser got frustrated
with me because I wasn't
understanding some fundamental
point, actually about springs.
So to demonstrate it, he kicked
the table at me and
said, is this acting
like a spring?
And I was so shocked.
I was just mortified
for like two days.
I just couldn't believe my
adviser had done that in front
of everybody else, and thought
that I must be
idiot and showed it.
So then eventually my fellow
grad students said, well,
actually he does that only
when you really cares.
So that's better than people
just switching off.
So I sort of consoled
myself with that.
But it did make a real strong
impression on me, how much
even a small push from someone
in authority can do.
So it's the same thing in
lecture, if when someone says
something wrong, if you
say, oh, why would
you have said that?
Even the slightest hint of that,
people magnify and will
pick up and be very,
very sensitive to.
So you have to be really,
really, really careful not to
let that happen.
So one way is the poker face.
So I practiced the poker face.
So when people are making
suggestions, for example,
about the wood block, why they
would act one way or another,
I just make sure I get in a
different mental state.
The mental state is
transcription.
So I just want to make
sure I understand
what people are saying.
And then I just write
that down.
Now, it's even there you
have to be careful.
Because you'll understand the
correct answer quicker than
you will the incorrect answer.
So you have to make sure when
people are explaining the
correct answer, you don't
complete it for them.
And then in contrast, when
people are explaining a wrong
answer, you ask lots of
questions, because
that too is a signal.
So the poker face is tricky to
do, but once you master it,
that's one good way of giving
yourself a pause and not
criticizing people for
their answers.
So there are various ways, but
you just have to be careful.
And if you do that regularly,
you'll find in a week or two,
you've overcome the presumption
people have that
it's dangerous to
ask questions.
But you do have to work at it.
Is it possible to incorporate
mastery learning at the
college level?
So actually, there is
a very interesting
experiment on that.
And it was done at MIT in
the 1970s, I believe.
It was called--
so it was called the
Keller Plan.
I don't know if they did it
for all courses, but the
physics courses were
taught this way.
I don't know if only that way,
or that was an option.
So it was in the 1970s,
which was a time of--
as people who were here
then said, it was a
very turbulent time.
And the turbulence actually
enabled lots of educational
experiments to happen, basically
the '60s and '70s.
So if you look at, for example,
the Feynman lectures
were in Caltech in the '60s, the
Berkeley physics course,
1960s, things like the Keller
Plan, the free schools at the
school level--
tons of experiments happened
in the '60s and '70s.
So the Keller Plan
was one of them.
It was mastery learning.
Students worked on problems, and
when they were ready for
the next piece, they
continued.
And from what I can tell,
it worked pretty well.
But then eventually it got
killed off by basically
faculty who said, no, I'd rather
teach and do lectures.
Because what's the point of the
faculty if the students
can learn really well
from the books?
So I think the Keller Plan
was a really good idea.
In school, I learned for five
years of high school math in
three or four weeks using the
Keller Plan, compared to the
normal pace in school where you
spend a whole year doing
trigonometry.
So the Keller Plan is a really,
really excellent way,
if you have reasonable books.
So now, what are the full
reasons it died?
I'm not really sure.
I need to check into that.
But people who were around then,
some of them said, yeah,
just people who wanted to
perform in lecture were really
sad about the Keller Plan
and wanted to go
back to the old way.
And so when the political
currents changed, so did the
Keller Plan.
How do I come up with these rich
and interesting examples
like the wood blocks,
and how often do
you incorporate demos?
Well, we'll talk about that
in Walter Lewin's lecture.
So if you saw Walter Lewin's
lecture, the one on the
pendulum, he must have had
four or five different
demonstrations.
They were short, but he had
many demonstrations.
And questions like this, if I
had 20 of these, I would use
20 different ones.
So usually I have four or five
of them that are a good long
time demo that are suitable
for, say, half
a lecture or longer.
And I use them.
So wherever I can find
them, I use them.
But not every single demo is
worth spending 30 to 40
minutes on.
So you have to think about
whether it teaches core ideas,
how it fits with the goals
of your course.
So for example, let me talk
through why I use this one.
Well, one of the goals that I
want is I want students to be
able to make physical
models themself.
I don't want them to just be
able to solve equations that
I've put in front of them.
So normally what you do is you'd
teach them the bending
beam equation, and then maybe
you'd show them this, and then
you'd do this in two
or three minutes.
But actually a much more
interesting question is not,
what's the solution to the
bending beam equation when the
beam's twice as thick.
The question is, what physical
model is responsible for
making sound?
When you hear sound, where
is it coming from?
When you tap this guy--
[TAPS A NOTE ON WOOD BLOCK]--
why is it making sound, long
before you're even discussing
the bending beam equation.
So that question is, to my mind,
much more interesting.
And so I'm very willing to spend
more time on that, and
having students develop that
feel, and have them argue and
realize that there's different
physical models.
It could be a standing
wave in the block.
It could be that the
block is bending.
How do you decide, and how do
you decide which one you're
going to hear more?
And then for each one, how
do you figure out how the
frequency's going to change?
So that, because it fits so well
with the course goals,
spend more time on it.
Why is the stiffness a factor
of eight bigger?
So that one, anyone who
wants to know, I will
explain after lecture.
Just come to office hours.
So there's a simple picture
using wood atoms.
Don't ask what wood atoms are.
How can you incorporate aspects
of mastery learning
into regular teaching?
Ah, so that's what interactive
teaching is all about.
So the reason mastery learning
works so well is that you're
not building castles
of knowledge on
sand, roughly speaking.
So normally what happens-- so
the extreme case is Cambridge
in England.
So the teaching system there
is you have an eight-week
term, and then you have a
six-week break, and then an
eight-week term, six-week break,
eight-week term, and
then 16-week break.
So the eight-week term, about
what we would do in a semester
is compressed into eight weeks,
just basically straight
dictation and lecture.
And the students have a hard
time really understanding
everything at that pace, so
they just take dictation.
And then you're supposed to
figure everything else out,
integrate it in the
six-week break.
So the problem with that is that
it's very inefficient.
It's very inefficient because
you haven't understood A. And
now B uses A, but A hasn't
really been understood.
So you're not going to
understand B. So now you have
A and B not really understood,
so you just write them down.
Now C comes along using A and
B, but A and B aren't
understood, so the problem
compounds.
Whereas with mastery learning,
only when you understand A do
you go onto B. And also when A
and B are solid, then you go
onto C. So your knowledge
castles are robust and strong.
And that's not true with
most teaching.
So how do you remedy
that problem?
Well one way is you ask
questions in lecture.
So here, plan interactivity
and build
it into your lecture.
So by asking students questions
you figure out, oh,
if only 20% or 30% or maybe even
40% of the students knew
the correct answer, and even
after discussion, you think,
oh, OK, well this is a
fundamental concept.
Presumably that's why you asked
the question about it.
But it wasn't mastered.
So better fix it, before
you go on.
So that builds mastery learning
into the regular
lecturing process.
And that's one reason
that interactive
teaching is so effective.
So one of the other questions
later in the sheets is, is
there evidence that interactive
teaching is good
and helps people learn?
There is actually
good evidence.
Maybe I should put some of
those papers online.
One is by Richard Hake.
He's now retired.
He's physics professor from
Indiana University.
So what he did is he did a
sample of physics courses
across the country, intro
physics courses that included
a total of 6,000 students.
And he asked the instructors
to describe how they did
everything.
And then everything was
grouped into either
interactive teaching or
regular teaching.
And just the scores that
students got on one particular
exam, which was a force concept
inventory, before and after--
they were given the force
concept inventory before the
class started and at the end--
they saw how much the
students improved.
OK, so if you improved 100%--
in other words, suppose you
started at 20% correct and you
got to 100%--
that was considered
a 1.0 gain.
If you went from 20% percent
to 60%, that mean you got
halfway to the maximum possible
score you could have
gotten, so half of the maximum
improvement, that
was a gain of 0.5.
So he measured the gain
for everybody.
So this is the gain on the
force concept inventory.
And this is the number of
courses in each area.
So it was roughly like that.
So this was the regular.
So the regular teaching, by the
way, included fantastic
teachers, people who were rated
highest lecturer in the
university and had won
lecturing awards.
And the interactive teaching
was something like this.
I'll put the paper online so you
can see the exact graph.
But basically, the worst
interactive teaching was
better than most of the
regular teaching.
And the regular teaching
hardly got
better than 0.2 or 0.3.
So if you wanted any more gain
than that, you really needed
to do interactive methods.
And I think that is because
you've incorporated mastery
learning into the curriculum.
OK, what do you do when the
students are really quite and
won't answer your questions?
Or flip side is, what if only
the quote 5% usual suspects
are the ones answering
the questions?
What do you do?
Well, so that is related to the
question of, are there bad
ways of incorporating
interactivity?
And there are.
The worst is the following,
which is--
I'll sort of parody it.
So we're doing relativity,
or nuclear physics.
E equals MC--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Squared, yeah.
OK.
So you'll find a lot of people
who normally wouldn't teach
interactively are now, they're
told or they hear that it's
good to teach interactively and
ask students questions.
But if you don't have any
practice in how to do that,
the easiest questions to ask
are just things like this.
And the problem with
that is not that
they're asking a question.
It's good to ask a question.
But the problem is that this
thing, this two, is just a
memorized fact.
So it's possible to answer it
just by memory, whereas if
there was actually some debate
about what it should be, you
could ask the students
the question.
But now, if you just ask people
question like that, and
you give people no time to
think, yes, you will get
answers just from the quote top
5%, the usual suspects.
So to avoid that, what you need
to do is give people a
chance to think on their own.
So that's one of the interactive
teaching
techniques, the idea of give
people a minute or even 30
seconds to think on their own,
so that you'll get answers
from a wider spectrum of
people, because they've
checked it out with
their neighbor.
And they feel safer in
volunteering and answer or
asking a question about it.
So that's how you avoid two
things, two problems at once.
You avoid the quiet students,
because you've given-- those
students are being quiet because
you've given people a
chance to think.
And you also avoid the problem
of just the usual people
answering, because you've given
everybody a chance to think.
OK, if we don't really
understand until we teach,
should we have students teach
each other in presentations,
or is that not worth the time?
My feeling is that huge big
presentations and having
students present to each other
is not so much worth the time.
I mean, it's worth the time of
the one person who's doing the
presentation.
But that's the main person
who learns in
that teaching session.
So there are several graduate
seminars, many I took as a
graduate student, that are
run the following way.
The professor just sits
back and each time--
they assign a list of topics,
and each student volunteers
for one topic to present
to everybody else.
Now, that is a fantastic way
to learn one topic in the
entire course.
And it does work for that.
And part of my Ph.D. Came out
of one of the topics that I
learned from one of those
courses, because I really
wanted to figure it out.
So it can work.
And it does work in some ways.
But it's not a very efficient
way, because all the other
people are just basically
passive.
Yeah, they read the stuff.
But now they're being taught by
someone who's just barely
mastering the field and is not
likely to teach interactively
with a large margin of safety.
So it's much better to have
students teach each other by
having them argue with each
other on small time scale.
So for example, if you remember
in the wood blocks, I
said, OK, are you with your
neighbor about your answer?
Well, now the students are
trying to teach each other.
Some students think, oh yeah,
it's due to the bending.
OK, well that turns
out to be correct.
But can you convince
your neighbor?
Well, in trying to convince
your neighbor,
you are doing teaching.
You're trying to figure out,
what's a way that you can do
it without writing down
50 equations.
That's exactly what you want
to do in teaching.
So I think it's a much better
way, is to build the
interactivity into the class
for everybody, rather than
having it as a rotating seminar
where just one person
at a time learns.
In organizing big ideas
into a tree, there are
often multiple ways--
for example, you can do current
understanding versus
history, or experiment versus
theory-- and it's often good
for students to know more than
one of these organizations.
How do you do that in
a course design?
Yeah, so unfortunately there's
only one time dimension.
There's three space
dimensions, but
only one time dimension.
So the course has to evolve
in one dimension somehow.
So you need at least
one organization.
But you're right.
You need other organizations
as well.
So the way I square that
circle is as follows.
So let's say time
goes that way.
So this is unit one.
Let's say it's one technique,
one mode of reasoning,
dimensional analysis.
Let's say this is another
mode of reasoning,
conservation, and so on.
So these are units.
And now you have topics.
Well, what I like to do is
I want to show other
organizations.
And why is that good?
Well, what you're doing
is you're connecting.
You're building threads
across.
And you're right.
You definitely want
to do that.
So what I'll do is I'll find
problems that can be solved
multiple ways.
Suppose this is, for example,
a problem about a pendulum.
Well, you can solve a pendulum
with dimensional analysis.
You can also solve a pendulum
with conservation laws.
So I'll do it again.
So this way, this method is
sufficient to solve it mostly.
This method is sufficient,
but now we're
revisiting the old problem.
So I try to find problems that
thread through, and maybe then
reappear over here.
So that gives you a cross
cutting organization.
So you can do that not just with
problems, but with, for
example, other principles.
For example, the history--
suppose you want to incorporate
history versus
current understanding.
Well, every time you mention
history and the importance of
history, you say, oh look,
there's yet another example
where we learned from history.
We learned it here.
We've learned it in this unit.
So now the students have yet
another structure to bind the
course together.
This is hard to do the first
time you teach the course.
What you'll do is this first
time you teach your course,
well, you'll probably do
it the regular way.
The second time, you'll maybe
reorganize it this way.
And the third time you do it,
you start building all the
bridges across it.
Because that's the only time
you actually see them too.
What are my thoughts
on grade inflation?
I wish every grade was an A. So
I think there isn't enough
of it, because of the studies
I said before.
So I'll talk about that in
the penultimate lecture.
I think most of these, yeah, I
think I've now answered with
other comments or questions
that are there, except for
one, which I'll save
for next time.